thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
it's still search and rescue the sounds
heard today from beneath the Atlantic in
the hunt for the missing Titan
coast guards say planes ships and
underwater vehicles are deployed in the
region as we hear what it's like to
travel in the submersible two miles down
you cannot stand you cannot need a stand
or stay on your knees you only sit uh
say 10 and a half hours in the same
situation
also tonight stubbornly High inflation
and a decades high level of public debt
the Grim backdrop for the economy as the
bank of England decides whether to raise
rates again
a victim of everything of beatings and
fear the yazidi woman kept as a slave
who finally saw her Tormentor jailed
[Music]
bringing Caribbean culinary culture to
Britain on the eve of the Windrush
anniversary we look at how it changed
what we eat
[Music]
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 13.
[Music]
a very good evening sounds noises even
what one expert described as banging has
been heard beneath the Atlantic in the
multinational search for the missing
Titan submersible
two underwater vehicles are already
involved more are due to arrive
overnight they are part of what the U.S
Coast Guard insists is still a search
and rescue mission
the five passengers on the submersible
are thought to have only around 14 hours
of oxygen left
tonight our correspondents are live in
both Boston and Newfoundland and we'll
look at how what would be a world
record-breaking rescue could possibly be
carried out our first report comes from
there and our International
correspondent John Sparks
it is vast and frequently hostile a
friend and adversary to everyone on this
island
look at the iceberg
no one in Newfoundland underestimates
the task now faced by search and rescue
teams as they attempt to locate the
missing submersible
a Canadian Patrol plane has picked up
sounds in the search area these noises
registered on Sonar boys but at the
moment the experts haven't been able to
identify them
yeah it has provided a glimmer of hope
as rescue teams move specialist
equipment into the area a sophisticated
deep sea submersible provided by the U.S
Navy loaded onto this ship overnight
it will join more than a dozen ships and
submersibles scouring the area with the
operator of the missing vessels Supply
ship the polar Prince saying they're
still optimistic the polar prints lost
contact with the submersible on Sunday
morning I mean realistically how
optimistic are you that you will find
the submersible and rescue the men on it
the equipment that's been mobilized for
this is um is the finest in the world uh
the most capable in the world we have to
hold on hope I think as you're aware
there's still life support available on
the submersible and we'll continue to
hold all hope until the very end
if the five men on Titan are still alive
their fate May rest in the hands of crew
member Paul orri najjolais a highly
experienced Mariner he's visited the
wreck of the Titanic some 35 times and
we tracked down a man who knows him well
Jose silver captained the supply ship on
one of his missions
he is very experimented Da Silva says
he's unflappable once his submersible
got stuck on the Titanic itself
was stuck in a Titanic peace and we had
to do a lot of Maneuvers to to be able
to bring the Hub back to the onwardship
a German adventurer who made the same
trip in Titan in 2021 told Sky News he
thought the voyage was safe but it
wasn't a pleasant experience you cannot
stand you cannot need a stand or stay on
your knees you only sit uh
it's a 10 and a half hours in the same
situation
the North Atlantic can be a formidable
foe The Depths and Tides frighten most
newfoundlanders this is a challenging
place to conduct a rescue operation it
was when the Titanic sank and it still
is now one official told us it's like
looking for a needle in a moving
Haystack
if the submersible is intact they won't
have much oxygen left but nobody on this
island is giving up
John Sparks Sky News Saint John's
Newfoundland
a wide range of ships aircraft and
underwater craft have been deployed to
the North Atlantic so how might they
find the Titan and if they did how might
its passengers be freed Skye's Adele
Robinson has been examining the details
behind a complex operation
this is a Race Against Time we know that
air supplies in Titan will run out
Thursday morning so how are Rescuers
trying to find it Well if the
submersible is intact it could be
floating on the surface or resting on
the bottom of the ocean that's
3750 meters down ships and planes have
been searching since Monday more
specialist equipment is on its way
including what are known as Sono boys
below 1000 meters it's pitch black so
the search is relying on sound in water
Sono boys normally used for hunting
enemy submarines work by either
listening for sounds in water or by
sending out pings and building up a sort
of picture through the returning Echo
sounds were picked up by a boy on
Tuesday but experts say this could just
be debris moving inside the Titanic
wreck so if Titan is found then how
could it be reached any successful
rescue would be a world first the
deepest ever Rescue of humans was the
Pisces three off off the coast of
Ireland in 1973 but that was at just 487
meters the Titanic is over seven times
deeper another challenge normal
submarine Rescue Tech can't be used the
Titan has no docking mechanism like a
military submarine and even NATO systems
only operate down to about 1 000 meters
but some positive news unmanned remotely
operated vehicles rovs are on site and
more capable ones are on their way which
can descend to over 6 000 meters the
American curve 21 and French Victor 6000
both have robotic arms that could attach
cables to the submersible and the
American fados system essentially a
winch and a cable long enough to pull
Titan to the surface that actually
successfully salvaged a helicopter from
a depth of over 5 800 meters in 2021 but
even with this kit experts are cautious
about a successful rescue
we've reached the critical point in the
operation time is running out really
fast now but we do have a valid solution
in case Titan is found in the time scale
the Americans have brought heavy
equipment in but that equipment has to
be brought forward to the ships that are
going to operate it fitted and these
vehicles have to descend to these
extreme depths that means that
everything has to go right the first
time there's no second chance for this
and the weather also has to be near
perfect
all hope Now lies in the coordination of
world-class expertise and Equipment
currently converging on that search area
in the North Atlantic
Adele Robinson there well let's speak
now to our correspondence in Boston and
St John's first to our U.S correspondent
James Matthews and James the message
from there is definitely do not give up
yeah hi Sally yeah the message is that
hope prevails although there is little
to no hard fact it seems on which to
base it efforts clearly are concentrated
around these noises held yesterday and
again this morning described originally
as banging half an hour apart now this
search team is being advised by a UK
Submariner Lieutenant Commander Richard
cantalia from the Royal Navy he will
have told them that the submariner's
distress call is two bangs one at the
top of the are one at the bottom they
bang at the top of the r allow Searchers
to go silent switch off propellers and
listen for the second bang that comes
half an hour later the coast guard gave
a news conference today they were still
describing these noises as bangs noises
that really could be anything but they
were still calling it banging this
afternoon although to be fair to the
Coast Guard spokesman he didn't say he
was aware of any half hour gap in
between it's a situation where any
glimmer of optimism finds a hefty
counter in a job described by the search
team as one of enormous complexity
absolutely James thank you and to John
Sparks now in Newfoundland the port
there in St John's has quickly turned
into a staging post for a multi-national
operation John
yeah it really has Sally and the people
who are organizing this rescue they
think they should have 10 vessels on the
search area within the next 24 hours
within the next 24 hours they've already
got some of these rovs these remotely
operated vehicles in the sea where they
heard these sounds and by tomorrow
morning they should have several more
including a very sophisticated ROV
that's been lent for them by the U.S
military it's this one that can plunge
to Deaths of around six kilometers so
really it's quite remarkable in the
space of a couple of days this operation
has been able to assemble some really
sophisticated kit they've given
themselves every opportunity to find
these men but they've got to do it
quickly we believe that the oxygen on
this submersible if it's still intact is
running out so if they're gonna do it
they really have to do it now
okay John Sparks and James Matthews
thank you both
now there may be a little respite
tomorrow for mortgage holders like Peter
Leslie he told us today that his
repayments have risen by more than 600
pounds since the bank of England started
raising interest rates and the bank
seems likely to increase that pain
tomorrow after inflation again proved to
be stubbornly high
well the rate of rising prices was
expected to have fallen last month but
instead inflation stayed static at 8.7
core inflation which strips out volatile
factors such as energy and food Rose to
7.1 percent up from 6.8 percent in April
and government borrowing led to UK debt
hitting a six decades high it's not been
more than a hundred percent of GDP since
1961.
it all adds to the pressure on the bank
of England over interest rates it's our
economics and data editor Ed Conway now
reports
that Leeds kirkgate Market there's only
one big topic of conversation these days
inflation the rate at which prices are
rising is taking its toll on businesses
like this hair and beauty shop people
are squeezing their budget because of
the living cost and footfall is not
there so our like sales are getting down
and down Neil a green grocer nearby sees
the Hallmarks every day English peas for
instance would put them on today because
of course you know it's the time of the
year but the five pound fifty a kilo
which is just you know ridiculous we
just had to let them passes the cherries
and put them back down again so it's so
expensive
there's all sorts of root causes for
this inflation High Energy prices the
post-covered bounce back but for this
food wholesaler in London there's also a
very UK specific explanation brexit has
made a major major impact which is
really underplayed and deliberated by
our government but um it's continuing to
have a marked effect on the cost
put it all together and you begin to see
why the UK has the highest inflation
rate in the G7 a rate with serious
Economic Consequences the good news is
that food price inflation now does look
like it might have peaked the band uses
whether it's oranges or cauliflower
prices are still Rising just at a less
fast rate and the worry for the bank of
England's perspective is that it's not
just this stuff it's everything else
it's Services it's restaurants inflation
is starting to look that word they hate
sticky and the stickier it is the more
they will feel they have to do about it
that spells higher interest rates but
even where they are right now they're
causing a real squeeze with homeowners
facing large increases in mortgage
repayments it's gone from 12 1087 I
think 1709 the last letter I got my
payments and the way it's going I
predict you could probably be up to 19 2
gram within another way that I'm looking
within the next three months this is
fast becoming the biggest political
story in town as was evident from prime
minister's questions 2009
family of the mortgage penalty now he
was warned by experts about this as long
ago as Autumn last year but he either
didn't get it didn't believe it or
didn't care because he certainly didn't
do anything perhaps the old gentleman
could explain why interest rates are at
similar levels in the United States in
Canada in Australia and New Zealand now
all eyes on the bank of England Once
Upon a Time people thought interest
rates would Peak at 4.5 percent but with
the bank widely accused of being behind
the curve on inflation markets expect
hike after hike after hike
at Conway Sky News
the bank of England's monetary policy
committee have to weigh up the different
pressures that are feeding High
inflation our business and economics
correspondent gurpreet narwan has been
untangling them
inflation really is the problem that
won't quite go away and you can see how
sticky it is here the blue line where
over the hump but it's not falling
anywhere near as fast as policy makers
would like it stayed flat at 8.7 last
month that's considerably higher than
the bank's two percent Target and look
at this before the lockdown it's also a
lot higher than the type of inflation
we're used to in the UK so we've got
some way to go to get it back down and
when we're thinking about what's driving
this persistent inflation well you can
see that food and drink is easing off
right the bottom there that red line but
prices here are still rising at an
annual rate of 18 so don't be fooled by
that red bar meanwhile at the top in the
blue it's Leisure Pursuits like eating
out Recreation and culture that are now
driving inflation
so even though prices are rising people
are still finding money to spend and
it's possibly why the bank of England is
worried about robust pay Rises that
workers in Britain have been securing
and this type of spending is becoming
increasingly a problem we will often
hear that inflation is a global problem
caused in part by factors out of our
control like the energy crisis but if we
strip away volatile items like food and
energy out of the headline rate we can
see that underlying pressures so that's
the red line or core inflation in the UK
is rising
that's something our counterparts in
Europe and the US are not grappling with
and all of this it's uncomfortable for a
government that's trying to figure out
how it may tempt voters next year ahead
of a general election government debt as
you can see here is a proportion of GDP
is at its highest since the 1960s and
soaring interest rates makes servicing
that debt all the more painful
so it's a tough State of Affairs for a
country grappling with the cost of
living crisis and a government that's
been talking tough on inflation but not
yet delivering the desired results
go print now in there and with interest
rates almost certain to rise further
tomorrow we'll be getting answers from
the experts about the cost of living
crisis that at 12 30 and 4 o'clock
tomorrow afternoon here on Sky News and
you can scan the QR code on the screen
to send us your questions we'd love to
hear from you
a young woman held captive as a slave by
a couple with the Islamic State received
some semblance of Justice today one of
her captors a German woman was sentenced
to more than nine years in jail after
being tried for crimes against humanity
and being an accessory to the genocide
carried out against the ZD people
Naveen Al speaking exclusively to Sky
News said she saw everything from
beatings to fear as our Middle East
correspondent Aleister bunker reports
the German defendant known as Nadine K
arrived in court covering her face from
the cameras to hear the verdict at the
end of this sixth month trial
sat opposite her just a few feet away
was Naveen Al the young yazidi woman who
she kept as a slave for five years and
whose evidence was crucial in convicting
her
Nadine K went to Syria and joined
Islamic State with her husband in 2014.
he is now in prison in Syria
during her five years as an is slave
Naveen here on the left was sexually
assaulted tortured forced to work for
the couple and pressed to convert to
Islam which he refused to do
she told her story exclusively to Sky
News
is
Naveen was found in a camp in Syria by a
Scottish filmmaker he helped her Escape
back to Iraq
we spent time with Naveen and her family
near their home in Iraq and showed her
for the first time a video of the moment
that she was finally safe
foreign
thousands of yazidis are still missing
and many remain buried in Mass Graves
Naveen told us that Justice today was
Justice for her and for all yazidis who
suffered because of Islamic State
Alistair bunkel Sky News
the UK today pledged more than two
billion pounds in loan guarantees to
help rebuilding in Ukraine it and much
much more will be sorely needed the
recent destruction of the Nova kovka dam
is a stark example of the issues facing
the country in the past two weeks the
flooding along the denipre river has
destroyed homes and farmland and
contaminated supplies of drinking water
our International Affairs editor Dominic
waghorn reports from Hassan
two weeks after the dam was blown parts
of her son are still underwater through
flooded streets we entered the worst
affected area to join the Region's
governor and mayor the task ahead they
say is immense
we need to clean everything and restore
the hydroelectric station and give
people back houses which they lost and
give back their belongings
the flood waters reached everywhere here
even The High Ground father Gregory
showed us his flooded church that have
been used to store aid supplies and
house the homeless she
for six months they were bombing us
every day they were shelling because we
are on the front line and after they now
flooded us we feel only cold towards
them and with that I can't even call
them people because it isn't even true
some Aid is getting in but also getting
bogged down most people seem to be
fending for themselves Vlad showed us
what's left of his house
you spent the last five years doing it
up all of that undone in the flood
somehow he's still smiling
Virginia
news
there is a saying that every evil will
be punished I believe they will be
punished
across the river behind his house
Russia's military isn't far away
it's only as the waters have gone down
that the true extent of the devastation
here is becoming clearer property after
property completely wrecked a thick
layer of black sludge lifted onto the
streets and the air thick with a stench
of sewage and Fuel and the clear-up
operation here is being made even more
complicated by the fact we're just over
the river from Russian forward positions
the economic cost is incalculable this
was a Print Works machines and supplies
now comprehensively destroyed
it looks like a natural disaster
Devastation on a massive scale ships
lifted and dumped on dry land but this
was done deliberately by Russia
a conference in London to discuss
rebuilding Ukraine after the war might
seem premature from here either way the
bill has just gone up by billions
Dominic wagorn Sky News fairson
well the Russian ambassador
today claimed that Ukraine was
responsible for destroying the Nova
kakovka Dam Andre Kellen also told Sky
News the UK is pursuing a militaristic
agenda against Russia in support of his
claim over the dam he provided what he
said was written evidence
if you are interesting I have specially
prepared it in English this is the least
of strikes it has 33 counts about 300
missiles during this time has been
launched and the attained so finally but
most experts say that missiles couldn't
have caused the damage the experts of
their sitting back in the rooms
thinking out loud what they think about
these effects
want to destroy the dam you were in
control of the dam you have the means to
destroy that down yes of course you have
the motive to destroy that damn and you
have the opportunity to destroy that
it's a year ago one of the major
generals of Ukraine has said that they
are going to blow up the dam to prevent
a rational offensive it has been
published in the Washington Post I'm not
sure in December almost here
Sky News understands the defense
secretary Ben Wallace is out of the
running to become the next head of NATO
it's understood that America NATO's most
powerful member instead wants the
incumbent Jens stoltenberg to remain in
post until next year
two people are missing and 24 have been
injured in a large explosion in central
Paris the cause of the Blast has not
been confirmed but officials have said a
gas explosion is one of the possible
explanations
police have arrested a man after two
people were hurt in an incident at
Central Middlesex Hospital in Northwest
London Police said one of them has
life-threatening injuries
finally dishes like jerk chicken are
part of the country's Cuisine now and we
have the Windrush generation to thank
for them
tomorrow marks the 75th anniversary of
the arrival of the Empire Windrush who
left the Caribbean to start a new life
in the UK
all correspondent Shimon Freeman Powell
has been looking at the culinary
cultural impact
yams mangoes and sweet potatoes foreign
foods that we take for granted but this
wouldn't have been the case 75 years ago
when people like Colin's dad were just
starting to arrive they realize that we
couldn't get our own produce and all
that was available was short short grain
rice and it wasn't very nice
using Connections in Jamaica and money
saved up from working in Nottingham coal
mines in 1955 his dad became one of the
first to open up a Caribbean food shop
in the Midlands challenges would have
been transportation is spent many hours
on the on the road actually trying to
get the things back to the back to
Nottingham trying to get through with
the banks that actually get financed and
so forth to get started that was not
very easy
tough but necessary and now the industry
is worth millions but the cultural value
priceless
I think that if it wasn't for the
Caribbean Supermarket the market in
general or the one or two storeholders
that sold planting yam and so on we
wouldn't be able to stay connected to
our culture and me as a second
generation again wouldn't know so much
of where I'm from
the Windrush generation accessing
Caribbean produce wasn't just about
having a taste of home it was about
preserving a culture which eventually
influenced Britain's
Wilfred is one of the UK's Only
commercial black Farmers famous for
producing British sausages with a
Caribbean twist
everybody loves the sausage he's also a
child of the Windrush generation I think
it's very very important especially on
something like on the 75th anniversary
of Windrush day to remind people that it
was a very brave entrepreneurial thing
to do and I'm so grateful that my
parents had that entrepreneurial Gene in
them otherwise I wouldn't be standing in
front of you today
Shimon Freeman Powell Sky News
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
papers in the Press preview including
this story on the front of the Daily
Mail Tori's turn on bank over rates
crisis so let me be talking about that
rather a lot and tonight we're joined by
associate editor at the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire and Daily Mail columnist
Sarah Vine see you after this short
break
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News in just a moment the
Press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive but first
are top stories the U.S Coast Guard
coordinating the search for the missing
submersible in the Atlantic has said
underwater noises have been heard but
it's not known what they are it's
projecting the vessels oxygen supply
will run out at eight minutes past 12
tomorrow UK time
the latest inflation figures show prices
are rising faster than expected interest
rates are expected to rise again
tomorrow
and in an interview with Sky News
Russia's ambassador to the UK has
accused Rishi sunak of pursuing a
militaristic agenda over the war in
Ukraine
[Music]
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and tonight
we're joined by associate editor at the
Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire and Daily
Mail columnist Sarah Vine good evening
to you both will be with you in just a
moment but first let's have a look at
what's on some of those front pages
their last hope the Daily Star reports
that there's just hours left to find the
missing Titanic submersible as oxygen
supply dwindles
Rescuers have promised not to give up
hope of saving the five people on board
the vessel that that story on the front
page of the Metro too
The Daily Express reports saving the
five people on board rests with a rescue
robot being sent to the scene of the
search
the financial times reports that the
bank of England is under pressure to
raise interest rates by as much as half
a percentage point because of stubbornly
high inflation
the expected rate Rises sparking fears
of a recession that's the front cover of
the eye
Tori's turn on bank over rates crisis
that headline leads the daily mail
tomorrow
The Daily Telegraph reports lung cancer
tests will be offered to every ex-s
smoker to try and boost survival rates
security guards on a Kenyan apple farm
that supplies British supermarkets have
been accused of brutally assaulting and
killing people suspected of trespassing
on the property that exclusive story on
the front of tomorrow's Guardian
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching us
and we're joined tonight by Kevin
McGuire and Sarah Vine great to see you
both thanks so much for joining us and
certainly inflation and interest rates
are very much dominating many of the
front pages uh Sarah to you first by May
let's look at the front page the
financial times stubborn inflation piles
pressure on Bank of England to take
tough action is their headline I mean
we've been talking about sticky
inflation haven't we but it really does
seem like it's stuck
very stuck um and of course Rishi wants
to get it down to three percent by the
end of the year which is looking
increasingly unlikely I suppose
um but the main issue for most people
will be interest rates because uh you
know we're a nation of homeowners and a
lot of people uh you know would have
borrowed
because interest rates have been
artificially low for so long they
probably borrowed more that they can
really afford
um and bought houses that were in
themselves inflated in price because of
the low interest rates so it's a sort of
pincer movement it's a kind of it's a
real horror show for uh homeowners and
um it's it's it's a really difficult
situation for the conservative party
because they are the party of home
ownership you know that's their
traditional space in the sort of
political Spectrum
um and you know you if you start to mess
with people's houses for most people
their home is their is their nest egg
it's the only real chance they have of
ever really making any money saving
anything and and now you're just
undermining all of that so which is in a
very difficult position he's been and
he's been very clear he's going to um
he's going to keep trying to get these
rates you know this station down and
that is going to have to mean more
interest rate Rises
it only feels that that's what we're
looking at uh tomorrow Kevin I mean it's
almost guaranteed isn't it the bank of
England is going to raise interest rates
again tomorrow the question is by how
much
no no absolutely the decision will have
been taken they'll have had an early uh
site of the inflation data made their
decision and I think it's noon tomorrow
we'll get the bad news and of course the
ft is talking about a half percent uh
rise Rises used to be you know uh 0.25
uh but going up uh half percent half
percent that would be the five percent
December 2021 what that's just 19 months
ago the rate was 0.1 so it's absolutely
shot up as uh Sarah says it's it's
crucifying people with mortgages who
have to remortgage uh Kia starma at
premises questions had a very effective
attack on soon ad by talking about a 2
900 pound
um Tory mortgage penalty that's the
average figure the resolution believes
families will will have to pay
households will have to pay extra and he
promised to get inflation down and it's
it's stuck at 8.7 when I saw the figure
this morning I thought am I reading this
correctly because it was forecast to
fall but it's been forecast to fall
before and it's actually gone up this
time it didn't didn't fall so yes it's a
it's a huge political problem now for
the UK concert of government but more
importantly it is a massive Financial
headache for millions of families yeah
absolutely the front page of the eye
Sarah certainly is is predicting uh the
possibility of a recession mortgage pain
deepens there's new rate rise Sparks
recession fears uh talking about how the
base rate may now hit at six percent
next year and certainly this is just
going to mean a lot of pain for
homeowners 400 000 people are going to
have to renew their mortgages between
July and September
and also you've got people who will have
paid very high prices for their houses
and the mark and of course the housing
market will I mean some people are
saying that it could drop by as much as
30 in some places so you know you could
be sitting on a house this is just
brings back memories of of the 90s you
know that disaster is disastrous very
high interest rates and negative equity
and people having their homes
repossessed only in a funny kind of a
way it's worse now because back then we
hadn't had this long period of very low
interest rates which had artificially
inflated the housing market and made
people stretch themselves beyond their
natural capacity to buy and we've also
got another problem which is the rental
market is very is very very expensive at
the moment so people could be coming out
of their homes and not being able to
afford to rent plus the interest rates
are of course affecting the people who
have bought houses on buy to let
mortgages they will start selling up and
that will cause cause problems for
tenants so it's not just a financial
problem it's it's a sort of Home problem
it's a home I mean we don't have enough
homes in Britain as it is uh and and and
you know places to rent and places to
buy are too expensive that could get a
lot worse yeah Kevin you hear older
homeowners talking about uh that period
that Sarah was referencing there where
interest rates went into double digits
and people were panicking overnight at
how they were going to be able to afford
their mortgages obviously we're not
seeing the same
level of interest rates but people are
more exposed these days in terms of how
much they borrowed just how do you think
that could play out for people this year
yeah I remember them going up for eight
to fifteen percent uh very very rapidly
and um and uh I'd got a fixed rate of
8.8 which I managed to see uh see it
through I was I was lucky if I remember
people having to take your lodges uh but
people just didn't have any any other
life because all they could do was pay
their their mortgage but at the time the
ratio between your wages and your
mortgage was a lot lower now because
house prices have been inflated for so
long and have risen so so quickly people
have got much bigger mortgages so so
they'll be hit even harder although it
won't be 15 you get five and six percent
that will proportionately be much harder
on them there'll be some people sitting
on paid off their mortgages they may you
know be able to ride it out they'll
their asset will just possibly go down a
little bit but there are just people
some people have to sell and downsize in
in a crisis so they won't get a good a
good price but the people are just going
to see uh family finances absolutely
wrecked they won't they won't be able to
eat out buy clothes go to events uh
holiday get new cars and that is where
the the I pick up on this this threat of
uh recession because the government says
high and high inflation is a big threat
to your living standards absolutely
absolutely is but at the same time if
the way to cure inflation is to actually
attack your living standards in another
Direction by putting pushing up not just
the cost of your mortgage but anything
you've got on a credit card or anything
else you've borrowed maybe bought that
car then you're going to get hammered in
a in another direction of course the big
push for information came from exterior
forces of Putin's invasion of uh of
Ukraine sending um oil and gas prices
soaring which fed through into into food
too and Britain has got a particular
problem because we import so much so
we've got higher inflation than the
other G7 major major economies but if if
the way of getting that inflation down
which has been pushed up mainly by
external factors is to hammer you at
home with interest rates then it just
seems crazy as you people are going to
get slapped uh from two different
directions and the economy can be
crashed not much of a cure is it if
you're going to crush the economy and
certainly Sarah that believer that we're
going to see the bank of England
probably pulling again tomorrow in terms
of raising interest rates just doesn't
seem to be working and this argument
that it's a global problem doesn't
really necessarily ring true anymore
when you look at inflation here in the
UK which appears stuck at more than
eight percent and then you look
elsewhere China where it's virtually
non-existent the US is a four percent
Europe at six and certainly the front
page of your paper tomorrow is is
looking at the fact that some Tories are
turning on the bank of England over this
crisis
yes well of course now the blame game
starts and you know
um the two of the conservatives are
blaming Bank of England uh you know uh
kirstama is obviously going to make a
lot of hey with this and politically it
makes perfect sense for him to do so
although I'm not I it doesn't I'm not
sure that labor has any particular
alternative
um it's going to be one of those
situations where everyone just blames
everybody else meanwhile ordinary people
suffer and also the other thing to say
is that I suppose back then in the 90s
people had more savings because as Kevin
was saying you know cost of living was
lower you could put more money away you
were paying a smaller proportion of your
salary towards your uh your living costs
now people live on debt you know so so
and and you know they they borrow a lot
of everybody has borrowed far too much
in the last sort of 10 or 20 years and
so people don't have much of a cushion
and I think that's that's really going
to hit
um that's going to really it's going to
cost the conservatives very dear
electorally I think yeah certainly uh
it's going to potentially be costly for
them politically but people are far more
worried about how much is going to cost
them financially at the front page of
the Guardian
um Kevin is looking at Labor's calls for
mortgage support but certainly that's
something the government has ruled out
they're not going to offer Financial
intervention for mortgage holders
because they say it'll be inflationary
no no absolutely absolutely an expensive
uh they say but Rachel Reeves the shadow
uh treasury secretary latest Chancellor
in Waiting really is is calling calling
for help one of the proposals is to
extend mortgage repayment uh periods
well that works if uh your your pain
largely Capital off but if you're in the
early part of your mortgage all almost
all the money you go obviously you've
got a 25-year mortgage goes on interest
and you can pay a lot each month and all
you all you really actually buy is a
couple of bricks I remember watching uh
you know my own Mortgage fall very very
slowly at at the uh at the start because
of it because most of the money was on
the interest and it wasn't on the
capital so this can only bail you out to
to some extent and only and only some
people I mean the truth is there is no
easy is the answer the Metro pick up on
renters uh two it's not just people with
mortgages 21 months the rents increases
of outstripped uh inflation generally
and they reckon now if you're outside
London the average renter we mustn't
forget you know
the government is in serious trouble
when it's got homeowners or home buyers
and it's got renters both coming at it
outside of London the average rent now
is
1136 pounds a month and in London more
than two thousand pounds more than two
thousand pounds is 24 000 pounds a year
that's 24 000 pounds cash that's after
tax and National Insurance so you'd be
talking around getting on for for 30 000
pounds a year you would have to be
earning gross just to pay your rent so
you know labor I suppose and the liberal
Democrats and others in opposition uh
I've got proposals but I'm not sure they
will fundamentally address a problem
which is rents are far too high and now
people are going to be absolutely
crucified by Rising mortgages yes it is
certainly such a worrying time for so
many people Kevin Sarah thanks so much
we'll see you again in just a sec uh
more for the front pages coming up after
this break uh including this front page
of the telegraph Titanic sub operator
too slow to raise the alarms that the
time is running out in that rescue
operation we'll be talking about that
after this short break
[Music]
thank you
then I think that the central point was
we were writing in the Balkan which was
essential collection of interviews with
the men and women who had come on that
boat and still survived
um and some of their descendants
and um when we were writing that we were
writing the origins story for what was
then black Britain
and black Britain basically meant people
like me with two black Caribbean parents
um and the reason we were Keen to write
stories because up until that point
what people knew about us was what they
generally speaking saw in the media
which was either black people rioting or
black people dancing at carnival and we
wanted to say there was much more to us
than that and these guys were they
fought in the War men in the media RAF
and they were adventurous they were
talented they were ambitious young
people
um we wanted to tell that story now
what's different now is that that group
of people to which I belong are really a
minority within the minority
um they are our children
um nearly a million of them who uh have
a Caribbean parent but also have a white
British parent and then any a bigger
group those who have come by what I call
the direct route from Africa about a
million and a half who um are people who
have arrived in the last 20 20 years or
so from East and West Africa and that's
changed the tone and the nature and I
think the sentiment of black Britain
quite dramatically and that's really
what we've added to the book a
description of those changes I think
when we wrote this book it was the
original book it was still slightly the
sense that
um we were foreigners and it's a bit of
a surprise that we were still here
whereas today
um you know you can't imagine
Britain without some of the people that
are that they said that of uh that group
and we're talking about
um you know
supporting stars like real Ferdinand or
entertainers like Leona Lewis
um you can't imagine Britain without
those people or what we're really seeing
now when we think about British identity
is that both the people who came in
their descendants
can't imagine being anywhere else
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview on Sky News it's good to have
you with us and with me this evening is
the associate editor at the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire and a Daily Mail columnist
Sarah Vine and of course the other big
story on so many of the front pages once
again uh tomorrow Kevin is this missing
submersible uh with five people on board
missing uh since Sunday and certainly uh
time is running out
no absolutely absolutely with the uh the
oxygen as you've seen some papers say 11
of the say 12 noon
um sounds are being picked up
but they don't even know where it is
never mind trying to to get it up so
while you always hope for the best I
think uh I think now it's a case of
fearing uh fearing the worst and
there'll be lots of questions uh asked I
I have picked up
um I was slightly surprised but some
people are not too sympathetic to the
group uh believing they spent a lot of
money on tourism and it was incredibly
dangerous and they should have gone
um and there are other arguments about
why do these five get so much coverage
and other bigger disasters possibly
including 750 people on a ship in the
Mediterranean that went down why don't
they get as much coverage but you just
really you just kind of see the drama
really also the the Heartbreak of the
family is knowing that these five people
are trapped in this this fight against
time uh that isn't on their side
yeah absolutely it doesn't really bear
thinking about but it certainly has
captured the attention of the world uh
Sarah and I was speaking to uh someone
earlier who was on for an interview who
used to be in the U.S Navy and he said
that even if the worst case scenario is
if they found them at this stage or on
the seabed they don't actually have the
equipment yet in place to pull them up
um and certainly there's already
criticism in the telegraph uh in an
article on it on page one tomorrow
um that they were too slow to raise the
alarm here in this rescue operation
yes I mean the thing is even if they as
as you say even if they get to them
because the thing is sealed with 17
bolts or something they can't even get
more oxygen in and of course they can't
raise them up quick enough
um to to open this up so it's a very sad
and difficult situation
um you know I I I I it's it's an old
thing I I you know I I can't understand
why anybody who wants to do something
like that let alone spend 250 000 pounds
doing it but
um you know we we've sent fewer people
to the bottom of the ocean than we have
into outer space it's a very very
hostile environment and
um there you know there have been
concerns raised about this operation
before
um so you know it's I think the reason
it's captured the imagination so much is
because it is it is a Race Against Time
isn't it to try and get them out and of
course the Titanic is is a sort of
eternally fascinating sea wreck
um but I just you know it seems very sad
I I I I feel terrible for their families
yeah absolutely
um but certainly the message is loud and
clear they are not giving up hope at
this stage for as long as there is a
time left then there's hope but it's
estimated there could be as little as 14
hours of oxygen left it doesn't bear
thinking about Kevin Sarah thanks so
much we'll see you again next hour uh
let's have a quick look at how your
weather's shaping up now
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
foreign
spells and widespread showers tomorrow
but the south and east look mainly dry
for the weekend most places will have a
dry and sunny start but there will be a
few showers mainly near Northern and
Southwestern coasts there'll be some
mist and fog too with the South and West
most at risk that mist and fog will
clear to leave sunshine and a scattering
of showers during the morning but
Scotland Southeast England and Northern
parts of both Island and Northern
Ireland will stay mainly dry top
temperatures will be mostly like today's
but the southeast looks like being a
couple of degrees warmer the afternoon
will bring little change although the
showers will become fairly isolated
towards the evening in the far west of
Ireland we'll see cloud and outbreaks of
rain moving in later on
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways